hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they come into us uh in
the next half hour we'll see what's
making uh the headlines with the
journalist and author rachel sharby and
the daily telegraph leader writer tim
stanley welcome to you both good to see
you uh well let's have a look at what's
on those front pages first off uh the
front cover of the observer covers
escalating tensions between russia and
the us its headline biden warns putin
you'll pay a heavy cost if you attack
ukraine
meanwhile the telegraph leads with
russia plots false flag attack to
provoke war
and then the sunday times also leading
with that story it is quoting the
defense secretary
in its headline which reads that this
has the whiff of munich uh in other news
the front of the express has the
headline coming soon brexit's big wins
for britain and they are looking at
jacob rees-mogg's first interview as
minister for brexit uh the mirror
meanwhile claims that levi bellfield's
recent confession to the murders of lynn
and meg russell
was a sick joke
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll be seeing on your
screens during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us
uh but let's uh go straight to our
guests now rachel sharby and
tim stanley lovely to have you with us
and we're going to begin with that
observer uh front page that we were
seeing there biden warns putin you'll
pay a heavy cost if you attack ukraine
and of course that's
been the issue tim hasn't it thus far
what is that heavy
heavy cost are sanctions
uh beefed up enough to finally make
putin listen
we're not talking of course about any
kind of direct military intervention by
the west as you say we're talking about
trying to make the cost of russia going
in as expensive as possible now the
united states and the uk are the ones
signing the loudest alarm bell over this
at the u.s
president biden spoke with putin
directly today and anthony blinken also
spoke with lavrov the russian foreign
minister the u.s is warning that an
invasion could come as soon as next week
how likely is that to what extent is
this about crisis diplomacy is it
putting on a show perhaps to put up
push-up gas prices or something like
that but i think there are a few signs
that are interesting one is that the uk
and the us have both withdrawn staff
from the country
that is a classic a thing that happens
when a conflict's about to take place
and noticeably russia is reported as
also starting to remove people from the
ground as well
that said i spoke to our foreign desk
with a telegraph today and we've got one
person in moscow we've got one person in
kiev
both of them
felt the conflict where they were
sitting right now was unlikely
in moscow because the state media simply
isn't talking about it
if putin is planning to invade he's not
letting his own people know and in kiev
there is an air of almost disbelief they
are they are prepared psychologically
for a fight and they will fight but they
can't quite believe that this would
actually happen and the ukrainian
president uh is saying that the west has
been stoking tensions too far why might
the west be doing that final point well
if the us and the uk have been talking
up a potential conflict a great deal
it's probably in part to frighten putin
off from doing it that by constantly
saying this is about to happen they hope
they're calling his bluff and putin
won't actually go ahead and do it so the
next couple of days we're probably going
to hear even more heated rhetoric but
the goal believe it or not is not to
stoke a crisis but to actually
discourage
i wonder rachel what you make of that
and actually just as we're talking uh
certainly tim you mentioned there the
diplomatic staff
being removed certainly by uh the us and
by the uk if not by other european
allies well some breaking uh news for
you just coming in now australia has now
announced that it is going to be
suspending all its embassy operations in
ukraine and removing uh the majority of
its staff from ukraine
rachel how important do you think that
is how significant when we talk about
diplomatic staff exiting it obviously
doesn't look good it certainly raises uh
fears fears that president biden
certainly has done nothing to sort of
quell
fears that president macron has been at
pains to try and quell where do you
think we are on this sort of sliding
scale of imminent invasion
well do you know i think it's worth
repeating what tim just referred to
which is the ukrainian president
getting very exasperated with this saber
rattling on all sides and saying
actually
you know this is this is the worst thing
you can do is to create this panic
and you know withdrawing embassy staff
is one of those things that provokes
panic
um
he says it's like the worst thing that
you could do
um he's really disgruntled with it
clearly um and he's horrified that there
are predictions even to the day of when
russia is expected to attack i think we
you know we have to take with a grain of
salt or you know a mountain of salt
all these kind of predictions about
you know
the us saying well we think russia is
going to attack on wednesday well i'm
sorry but
the u.s got completely and utterly
blindsided by what happened in
afghanistan last year
so the idea that u.s intel now knows to
the day
what russia is planning
i find hard to swallow
um
and it's also
it's also the case that
you know this kind of
uh
false flag operation that
britain is claiming
british intel is claiming uh certainly
from the telegraph front page uh should
be treated with equal skepticism i do
think there is obviously um it's clear
that diplomacy or diplomatic channels
will continue
um the sides have left that prospect
open
um and that
you know there needs to be
a means to provide
uh putin with a with a ladder to climb
down over the next few days certainly
and i wonder tim if what you make of
that that this sort of question about
the intelligence and the quality of the
intelligence coming uh through certainly
ben wallace saying that russia uh
invading the ukraine is highly likely
sort of towing the the u.s line they're
sharing intelligence on that he says it
has the whiff of munich uh a sense there
that some in the allied western nations
are appeasing uh russia
first of all on the intelligence because
i think this is very interesting america
has played an unusual game in the last
couple of weeks what it's essentially
done is it has handed over everything
that it says is intercepted to the media
so every time there is a whiff or a
rumor about the russians doing something
the americans have put it out there some
journalists have actually protested
against this because they say we are not
here simply to report what intelligence
you claim to have without any kind of
verification because whenever
journalists say okay so you say there's
a false flag operation planned please
tell us what your evidence for this the
u.s then doesn't hand it over but it's
not handing it over because i say it is
almost almost indiscriminately just
revealing everything it claims that it
has
the goal of that sounds a bit barmy but
the goal is a rational one which is to
let us know in advance everything putin
might do so that putin will be spooked
out of doing that one thing
secondly on the question of appeasement
ben wallace has used this very emotive
uh term that it's a munich moment the
implication being that if we don't take
a stand in ukraine if the west isn't
united and allied around ukraine then
there's a risk that putin like hitler
could then push try his luck on poland
he could go further into western europe
well
i i think that's a stretch as a metaphor
i don't think that's quite what putin's
ambitions are but i
in essence he's correct
in that if the west doesn't take a stand
at ukraine which is on the border of
nato then the next country if putin is
interested in ethnic nationalism and
reestablishing the authority of the
soviet union the next countries he'll
have his eyes on will be nato members so
what the uk and the us is saying here is
we don't want conflict we're not going
to put soldiers into ukraine this is not
going to lead to a global conflict of
any sort all we're saying is we have to
say no to putin somewhere and we want to
try to discourage it here so that he
won't try it elsewhere yeah exactly and
of course trying to work out where that
no comes from is is the the sort of
million dollar question at the moment um
there's one uh article that is on at the
front of the observer this is uh mayor
london mayor issues threat to veto
appointment of the met chief
rachel this one about sadiq khan uh
potentially involved now in a standoff
with the home secretary
yeah that's right potential showdown
over the appointment of the new met
chief
um
it's to do with uh sadiq khan basically
saying look whoever is appointed needs
to get that there has to be a culture
change at the met um you know following
all these revelations of you know police
officers bragging about violence towards
women and sending racist uh and
homophobic messages um and a really
toxic culture at the met which the deep
calm writes in the observer reminds him
of the bad old days in the 70s and 80s
when it was just you know perceived as
misogynistic sex sexist homophobic
racist
um so he's determined that the new chief
will have a plan and be of a mindset to
take on this culture and has said that
he's you know prepared to use his veto
if the person put forward does not meet
that criteria um absolutely um
tim
what do you make of the way that this
has all been handled this uh this uh
cressida dick's resignation and how
they're going to try and find the new
met commissioner
the implication of of khan's
intervention is that pretty patel
might be more interested in finding
someone who is anti-woke and tough on
crime than interested in tackling the
culture uh within the police force
although these two things are are not
not necessarily in contradiction uh
people who are concerned about the
police force being distracted by work
causes
are also appalled at the things that
were reported to have been said and done
at sharon cross police station equally
people who are concerned to maintain
good community relations and to root out
bigotry in the met also want to see
things like burglaries being
investigated and punished
so i i don't think there necessarily
needs to be attention here but there's
obviously
obviously there is space for a political
row here and we'll have to see how it
plays out in the next few days
absolutely well let's uh let's have a
look at the telegraph now uh the front
page that we were talking about earlier
families denied holidays amid a million
covid app blunders this about a million
vaccine records being affected in these
nhs uh blunders and rachel it means well
the implications for people particularly
trying to go on holidays are quite
serious aren't they
yes so the telegraph is reporting that
that million figure that you just
mentioned could be the tip of the
iceberg um and this is um readers
getting in touch with them
to alert them to this that the nhs app
appears to have blundered by either uh
disappearing
people's
vaccine passports or getting the
information wrong as far as i can make
out so then people had this awful back
and forth
trying to get the app to show their
vaccine passport without which of course
uh they couldn't travel
when you look at the summer last year so
you know just a really stressful
situations travel last year was as we
know already pretty stressful with
having all this documentation quite
expensive with all the tests that you
needed and so to add this to the top on
top of it and you know presumably
prevented some people from going on
holiday obviously a very uh stressful
and upsetting situation yeah absolutely
and we all know exactly how difficult it
was to travel uh last year uh tim the
sunday express on its front page has an
exclusive with jacob reese uh mog coming
soon brexit's big wins for britain uh it
is uh a first interview with the new
minister for brexit what do we learn
uh well i don't know because i haven't
seen the inside of the paper but what i
can say with regards to jake it's rather
embarrassing because it says lots of
opportunities for brexit see page four
and then unfortunately i can't get to
page four uh we'll have to find out what
they are but for jacob personally uh the
the cabinet reshuffle has been
a question of onwards and sideways uh he
he didn't get quite promoted he got
moved from leader of the house uh to
being in charge of brexit opportunities
that's that's thought partly to be a a
recognition of his loyalty in defending
the prime minister the last few days but
also recognition that uh he may have put
a foot wrong when it came to the owen
patterson up there so now he's in charge
of with realizing brexit opportunities
well that's potentially going to put him
in conflict with the treasury which is
not only reluctant to spend money but
also there are a couple of big brexit
opportunities which brexiteers in the
tory party say
the government is not exploring such as
cutting vat on fuel so it'll be very
interesting to see how that plays out
inside the tory party all right and
rachel what do you make of that jacob
rees-mogg as the new brexit minister
i mean
can i just say that i think brexit
opportunities revealed on a page that we
cannot see
is the perfect metaphor
he's just do not exist
do you know what i think that's the
perfect place to leave it there with a
wonderful uh metaphor see page four of
the express you have uh been asked
thank you very very much to both tim
stanley uh and rachel shall be there my
guest for uh the press preview